dc fans
are
you
ready
the dc universe is about to change
dc fandom is coming
one day where everything dc comes alive
the epic global event that will take you
on a journey
beyond your wildest expectations
nothing compares to this featuring the
biggest stars
the biggest titles
the biggest reveals
join me join me join me at dc fandom
2021 it's gonna blow people's heads off
one day one show for you the fans save
the date you won't want to miss it
dc fandom join us live october 16th
and be the first to see the new trailer
welcome back everyone this will be my
new dc fandom trailer for the batman the
other dc movies they'll be releasing
footage for there's a couple new scenes
from all the different movies in this so
i'll explain what's going on there's a
bunch of easter eggs obviously it's
going to be crazy this weekend if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all those videos of
course i'll be doing videos for all the
trailers they release it is going to be
trailer city in a couple days if you
have no idea what's going on dc fandom
is coming this saturday and they
released this trailer just to hype up
all the other trailers they're dropping
is a trailer for a bunch of trailers
mostly for the batman trailer in a
couple of the other upcoming movies like
the flash movie which also has two other
versions of batman the black atom
trailer and a bunch of early footage for
everything else within this they did
include some new teasers with brand new
footage they haven't released before so
i'll talk about that and since the last
batman trailer we've learned a lot more
about what's going on with matt reeves
batman universe and their overall plans
for the future of batman in the dc
movies or at least a version of batman
in the dc movies because now we do have
three versions of batman running around
in the movies so we'll start with the
batman stuff just because that's sort of
like the crown jewel of dc fandom this
year and then i'll talk about the new
footage and easter eggs for the other
movies like the black adam footage and
some of the other flash movie footage in
here there's just a little more footage
of robert pattinson's batman catwoman
the riddler the batmobile mixed with
some footage from the trailer that we
saw last year and on top of that you may
have also noticed some small changes in
the older footage if you've watched a
lot of trailers for a lot of different
movies different studios you probably
noticed that between the first teasers
in the last trailers for movies things
like the color correction the special
effects the way they frame shots all
changes a little bit so that sometimes
you think that you're looking at
different footage even though they use
the same footage in a lot of trailers
the cool thing about the last batman
trailer we got last year is that when
they released it matt reeves had only
been filming the movie for a couple
weeks they legit released a long ass
teaser trailer and they'd only been
filming for a couple weeks in the boot
most of that footage was only from like
20 percent of the movie but we have a
pretty good idea for what the story is
the tone and where matt reeves is taking
this robert patinson version of batman
is being referred to as more of a batman
horror movie than we've ever seen before
not a legit horror movie like the
halloween movies like not a slasher
flick just more horror elements in a
more horror bend on the material than
say christopher nolan's batman dark
knight movies but this new batman movie
borrows a lot of inspiration from the
long halloween story it seems like it's
set around the halloween holiday because
of all the halloween costumes for the
other justice league characters like
there's a superman halloween costume
walking around in the footage so it just
lends itself to a little bit more of the
heightened horror elements that you see
around the halloween holiday it is not a
copy paste version of the long halloween
story it's just borrowing some
inspiration from that some elements and
it's using the riddler to sort of set
off this first movie in a trilogy with
sort of a zodiac type of twist on the
character like the david fincher zodiac
version of the riddler with the whole
murder mystery of it all mixed with the
darker scarier take on the batman mythos
it is funny that i make that zodiac
comparison because if you've been
watching the news this past week they
actually just revealed the true identity
of the real world zodiac killer that
that movie was based on like legit they
just found out who he was a couple years
after the david fincher movie came out
so the real zodiac killer would have
been able to watch the movie that was
done about him but as you can see from
all the footage matt reeves just going
with a darker scario take on the batman
mythos and the other really big change
that matt reeves has said that he's done
with his version of this new batman
universe that he's building is to put
this movie earlier in batman's career
but not doing a batman origin story
that's why he's doing it is year two
batman in one of the big reasons why he
chose to do it that way is that he could
also do origin stories for most of his
bigger rogues gallery of villains like
catwoman even though she's not really a
villain technically penguin riddler even
the new version of the joker in the
sequels that he'll eventually probably
work up to so yes it's all about doing a
darker world's greatest detective style
batman murder mystery thriller movie
neo-noir style but really it's about
leaning hard into the villains in a way
that batman movies haven't done in a
while like matt reeves legit said that
he was just as excited to do a movie
about batman villains as he was to do a
movie about batman himself the villains
are often you know some of the most if
not the most exciting part of the movies
i mean the rogues gallery is incredible
and what i wanted to do
was i wanted to see a batman that was
not an origin tale but was sort of in
these early days but that meant that a
lot of the characters who are the rogues
gallery characters are in their origins
in a way and so we have a selena kyle
who's not yet catwoman we got a lot of
batman villains during the christopher
nolan dark knight movies but he didn't
focus on them quite as much as it sounds
like matt reeves is focusing on the
villains in fact they've also confirmed
two spin-off series from the batman
movie for hbo you've heard about at
least one of them maybe the other two no
release dates for either of them yet but
the first one is the gotham city pd
series that they talked about a long
time ago and it sounds like that is
actually now turned into more of an
arkham asylum series with the gotham pd
and gordon just being a huge part of it
like i said matt reeves leaning harder
into the villains it's much easier to do
that when you take an arkham spin on a
tv series the second batman movie
spin-off that you probably just heard
about is the full-blown penguin series
for colin farrell's penguin who said
that he's barely in this first new
batman movie and probably won't be a big
character till the sequel so don't be
surprised if they do other hbo series
for more of the batman villains between
batman movie sequels in this new trilogy
in the next several years but robert
pattinson is supposed to be the new main
version of batman in the movies the way
that they view it at warner brothers but
because they're rolling full multiverse
with the dc movies using the flash movie
and they're bringing back both ben
affleck's batman from the main justice
league earth and michael keaton's batman
from earth 89 or whichever earth you
want to call his earth from the tim
burton batman movies robert pattinson's
batman isn't going to be the big
crossover batman of the other dc movies
at least right away matt reeves made it
sound like he just wanted to do his own
thing in his own corner of the
multiverse for at least right now and
that was the reason why they wanted to
put it on earth too which is where it's
supposed to be taking place maybe
there'll be some easter eggs or a
reference for his batman during the
flash movie when the flash is traveling
the multiverse there is a little bit of
flash movie footage in this they're
going to be releasing a teaser trailer
in some behind the scenes for it if you
remember there was a leaked flash movie
promo from earlier this year with a
whole bunch of concept footage and
details about what's actually happening
in the movie with the scenes it showed
ezra miller's flash inside michael
keaton's batcave it showed another
mystery character that they kept
blurring out with spoiler warnings and i
believe that's because the character is
supposed to be the secret villain of the
movie in a dark version of the flash but
it's going to be like dark flash versus
ezra miller's flash instead of the
villain being straight up eobard thawne
reverse flash because they're doing the
flashpoint inspired story and if you saw
the new previews they released of all
the different logos this logo of the
flash symbol spray painted red and
yellow over one of michael keaton's
batman suits i believe is supposed to
represent his dark flash character then
there's also supposed to be the black
adam trailer with actual footage from
the movie there are couple scenes of him
in his costume in this trailer here this
is basically what he looks like but they
kind of cut him off at the shoulders
here this is what the full costume looks
like behind the scenes this is also
hawkman's costume looks familiar this is
the first look at cyclone in her costume
and this this is obviously pierce
brosnan he's playing their doctor fate
of the dc eu i'm assuming we'll see him
in his costume in that teaser trailer
they release but they're using the black
adam movie to introduce the dceu just as
society so we might actually also get a
spin-off for their team in the future as
well they do have a version of the
justice society on the star girl tv
series featuring john wesley ships jay
garrick i'm also kind of hoping that
they feature john wesley's ship as some
character some cameo scene inside the
flash movie it would be a bummer if he's
not at least in there somewhere also
probably some sort of cameo scene or
some sort of reference to grant gustin's
flash from the arrowverse because of the
big justice league crossover in crisis
on infinite earths and on the other side
of the black adam coin they are supposed
to release some sort of new shazam 2
teaser trailer they released one a
couple months ago and i did a video for
it so i'll link that below in the
description but it was just a comedic
clip of him showing up inside their
living room to highlight the brand new
costumes like they got full-blown
redesigned costumes that look way better
and they reveal that they've changed the
way they're doing the merry marvel
character because now the actress who
plays the real version of mary is old
enough in the right size to play the
superhero version of mary marvel when
her powers are activated but this is
really just scratching the surface in
terms of the big trailers they'll be
releasing there'll be a peacemaker
trailer for the hbo series probably an
official release date for that too
trailers for most of the other tv shows
and maybe some kind of early preview for
that green lantern hbo series because it
has been a hot minute since they've
revealed any more information about that
but if you have any big questions or
requests for the videos that i do for
all this stuff just let me know in the
comments below and make sure you have
alerts enabled for my channel so you
don't miss any of those trailers
everyone click here for that brand new
marvel daredevil announcement about him
coming back and click here for my brand
new eternals trailer video and easter
eggs thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys
in the next one
[Music]